dafür gerade 500.000 euro will das
hamburger aktionshaus dächer heute ein
angeblich von vincent van gogh
stammendes gemälde versteigern das ist
für so ein bild ziemlich wenig geld oder
weiter bei mir denn jetzt weiter starten
unser kunstkenner auch 500.000 euro das
ist doch fast ein schnäppchen oder hatte
für einen originalen van gogh gemäßigt
muss man sagen wobei man auch sagen muss
die frühen van gogh werke die etwas
dunkler sind aus einer holländischen
zeit werden im handel auch etwas
schlechter bewertet als die knallig
bunten aus seiner französischen zeit
aber 500.000 ist ein übermäßiger preis
nur der muss auch erstmal erbracht
werden heute tatsächlich aber um dieses
bild gab es ja eine relativ kuriose
geschichte wo es auf einmal herkam und
ob es dann echt ist oder nicht kann es
ja ganz kurz mal auf den neuesten stand
bringen was da genau passiert das kommt
aus einem familienbesitz in schleswig
holstein ein früherer imbiss inzwischen
verstorbener imbissbesitzer hat dies von
einer reichen dame erworben deren
großvater angeblich das bild auf dem
pariser kunstmarkt um die
jahrhundertwende also zum zwanzigsten
jahrhundert erworben hat es ist denn bei
einem auktionshaus gelandet das
eigentlich auf kunst sondern auf
industrie waren spezialisiert ist es gab
viele tests viele untersuchungen einige
gutachten von experten die die echtheit
zertifizieren
das ok das amsterdamer van gogh museums
quasi der großen instanz das gibt es
nicht da dieser echtheit stempel fehlt
halt das heißt dass schneider dem preis
wahrscheinlich auch noch mal das
schmälert den es gibt eine gewisse
unsicherheit ja aber nun gibt es ja auch
eine neue untersuchung auf ganz anderen
weg mit künstlicher intelligenz und die
spricht wiederum für das bild jetzt wird
es heute versteigert wir wollen da
einmal aktuell reinschauen bei 500.000
das war das anfangsgebot und wir sehen
es steht auch noch mal bei dem anfangs
geburt das läuft aber auch noch eine
ganze weile bis heute abend also diese
aktion deswegen 500.000 euro wir haben
gerade schon gesprochen ist jetzt nicht
also ist natürlich eine summe aber für
einen echten van gogh dann doch nicht
ganz so viel
würdest du sagen vielleicht ein kredit
aufnehmen alle legen zusammen und am
ende kann man es dann in ein paar jahren
für eine million verkaufen hat richtig
gewinn gemacht man muss
ein bisschen gottvertrauen haben in
dieses bild also ich würde nicht die
hand ins feuer legen das original ist es
spricht aber von den fakten her vieles
dafür kreditwürdig nicht aufnehmen aber
ich sag mal so wenn ich ein pralles
konto hätte mit noch viel mehr als
500.000 dann würde ich sagen da mal ran
zu gehen wir mal gucken was der tag
bringen ob sich zumindest ein bieter
findet diese so ähnlich oder ob es gegen
ende bis 18 uhr läuft die aktion
vielleicht sogar noch ein richtiges
bietergefecht gibt weil meistens spielt
sich so was sie am ende ab bei einer
online auktion geht es ja nicht gleich
hoch sondern viele warten ab was
passiert und drücken denn erst zehn
minuten vor schluss aufs knöpfchen
trotzdem sollte ist echt sein dann hätte
ich wenn ich jetzt kaufen würde in
bayern auf jeden fall noch ein teures
gemälde in der hand oder ist auf jeden
fall würde ich mal streichen
du hast gute chancen es muss aber den
segen noch kriegen vom van-gogh-museum
weil sonst bleibt es ein
spekulationsobjekt